do you think uh Donald Trump will come
back to the platform he recently posted
on Truth social about this
podcast uh do you think truth social is
a funny
name you you know every time you post on
Truth social it's a truth yes well every
time like 100% it like like it's
impossible to lie truth
social I just find it funny that every
single thing is a truth like
100% yeah that seems unlikely I think
girdle will say something about that
there's some mathematical contradictions
possible if everything's a Truth uh do
you think he'll come back to X and and
start posting there I mean he I think he
owns a big part of Truth so truth social
to yeah truth social that truth is a
concept he owns truth you B it um so I
think I think uh Donald Trump I think he
owns uh a big part of Truth social so um
you know if if if he does want to post
on the X platform we would allow that um
you know we we obviously must allow a
presidential candidate to post on our
platform Community notes might be really
fascinating there the interaction notes
is awesome let's let's hope it holds
up yeah again in in in the political
climate where it's so divisive and so in
so many intensely viral posts yes
Community notes it's like it seems like
essential breath of fresh air yeah it's
great um in fact the I no no system is
going to be perfect but the the batting
average of community notes is incredibly
good
I've I've actually frankly yet to see an
incorrect note that survived for more
than a few
hours